hi I'm the developer of democracy 3 and
we have a expansion pack for the game
coming out so I thought I'd talk what it
talked about what its kind of designed
to do the expansion packs called social
engineering and it's a bunch of new
policies and new dilemmas that reflect a
kind of different approach to playing
the game now the basic game democracy 3
most of the policies in there kind of
like hard policies in the kind of thing
that the government's do in a very
obvious way like raise taxes or change
the level of government spending on
education and stuff like that
but I think what's more interesting is
there's lots of kind of small and subtle
ways in which the government's affect
the population the aren't really talked
about they're not in government
manifestos or anything like that and
they have a more subtle long-term effect
so social engineering is an expansion
that adds that as an option to the game
so you have the kind of thing that you
don't consider to be a major public
policy like subsidies for cycling or
cycle lanes or for example sort of
public awareness campaigns on stuff like
the dangers of alcohol consumption
encouraging people to eat healthily
stuff like that but there is compulsory
food labeling these are all kind of
fairly minor things that have sort of
subtle background effects on the
population but I think they're quite
interesting from the point of view of
the game because what they do is they
allow you to change not just how happy
certain groups of voters are any
particular time but they allow you to
change the actual sort of makeup of your
country so for example if you subsidize
bicycles then you'll get more people
cycling over time and it's not
necessarily the your make particular
groups
people happy but for example you'll
reduce the number of motorists that's
quite an obvious one but there's a lot
of fairly subtle things and this is a
sort of interest of mine the kind of
like background ways in which government
decisions and so social policy affects
the makeup of a population and one of
the dilemmas that's added in this
expansion which i think is a good one is
who'd upon banknotes every now and then
in a bank that exchange and you don't
really think that that's a major
political decision but it kind of is and
it's especially noticeable if like me
you've to cling to the states I'm from
the UK if you look at a British this is
a ten pound now first of all on the
phone we have the Queen which is kind of
a statement really you know we actually
have the Queen on all of our stamps and
banknotes and coins and if you're
Finnish you take it for granted but it's
a kind of reestablishment of
the monarchy and belief in the monarchy
and permanence of the monarchy which is
of course political statement the other
side of this one and we have Charles
Darwin which again we don't think about
much at all but there's probably certain
states and there may be Texas and
Florida or wherever where that might not
be very popular
and become flipside of that is here we
have a $50 bill and like all banknotes
it seems in the u.s. it has in god we
trust' written on it and again much
people don't don't consider that to be a
big deal or take that too seriously
obviously that is a pro religious
statement so when you make a decision in
government as to you know who you put in
your bank bag that that's an actual
decision that is either going to shape
society in a very subtle background way
and what I wanted to do is introduce
that whole thing to democracy 3 because
a lot of people playing democracy 3 just
to win it's not just about winning it is
about changing society
to reflect the kind of society that you
want order you want to have in the game
just for fun so whether or not you can
like change France to be a little pro
capitalism extreme economically
right-wing country that will be a
challenge you know can you convert the
United States to be a socialist
communist utopia as it were again you
know that's a challenge and I think you
can only really do that in a subtle way
over the very long term and the basic
game democracy three doesn't have enough
ways to do that I don't think so social
engineering adds I do 26 new policies
and I think it's a dilemmas that allow
you to have more control over stuff like
that so I hope you like it
you